google has a better sense of what we
prefer than we do and Google certainly
has a better sense of what we prefer
than our partners do III can vouch for
that in my marriage
you know these algorithms are going to
start making more and more of these
decisions
why did my watch just tell me to stand
you know
we've basically giving up our agency
completely one of the big precursors to
solving these problems in many ways is a
restoration of trust
Jack I believe that universal basic
income is central to a restoration of
trust yeah hello welcome to another
episode of Yang speaks where I sit down
for a fascinating conversation with the
co-founder and CEO of both Twitter and
square Jack Dorsey Jack's one of the
most profound thinkers on what the heck
is coming next in the world and so we
talked about the future of work
mindfulness universal basic income of
course one of my favorite subjects in
the world how is data owned and shared
what he's concerned about for the future
what he would suggest to the president
the future of small business and after
all of that there's a really big
announcement at the end so stay tuned
for my sit-down conversation virtually
of course with Jack Dorsey
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome the yang speaks the one the only
CEO of both Twitter and square and
co-founder of both mr. Jack Dorsey Jack
welcome thank you so Jack I don't know
if you remember this I've been waiting
to see you to ask you this but you and I
met briefly six years ago in Detroit you
spoke at this tech ahna me conference oh
yeah and I met you backstage very
briefly so I just wanted to take a trip
down memory lane and say you might not
remember this but I was like Jack Dorsey
I could 2014 I remember now
you seem like such an elevated human you
also look the part kind of - you have
like this sense of Jack from the future
thank you and I think part of it is that
you meditate you're mindful like you
take this stuff very seriously about
like awareness of your own health
surroundings and I think it gives you
like connectivity to like the the world
at large in a way that many people don't
necessarily experience but when I want
to clear my head one of the things I do
is try and get away from Twitter
particular period of time and I know you
have techniques that you use to try and
be more mindful one thing I'm curious
about is whether any of the tools or
techniques you use utilize technology
and do you think that there's a way that
technology can actually make us more
mindful and aware as opposed to possibly
the opposite I do I mean I think
mindfulness and meditation for me as a
practice of honing your skills of
observation and making sure that we are
present and aware of everything that
we're doing and that we're not blindly
reacting to it and just falling into a
hole but we're fully aware of the what
and also the why behind it and able to
make choices there
so I've structured a lot of my work
around this concept of like how do I get
how do I focus more on one thing and
most of my day is actually spent on on
this iPhone here and the reason I use
this instead of a computer is there's
only one app open at a time so I
definitely take my walks I definitely
meditate without a device and whatnot
but I think it's more about how we train
our minds to to to really observe it
you've you've always booked 21 lessons
for 21st century
I think his phenomenal his last chapter
his last less than the twenty first
lesson is around meditation he believes
and I think we all feel this right now
that google has a better sense of what
we prefer than we do and Google
certainly has a better sense of what we
prefer than our partners do III can
vouch for that in my marriage and think
your kids I mean Google will have a
better sense of even who they are than
they might and his recommendation is a
practice of meditation actually helps us
understand why we're doing the things
that we're doing why we react in the
ways that we do and it's important for
us to have that base level understanding
and self-awareness because otherwise
we're just off shooting every single
decision to these algorithms and then
who are we I mean it's it's the it's the
wali Future that one of my favorite
Pixar movies that you know that that is
the future where we're headed to and I
think meditation is one of those tools
that that can at least make us aware of
the choices or we're making agency
towards technology that that's certainly
like a massive issue because I do have
kids and to the extent that we had
screen time limits they've gone out the
window with the covetous I've no idea
how much how much time they're spending
so you just talked about how Google
I know me better than my partner you've
talked about how you're concerned about
also the future of data ownership and I
and it's like I feel like with square
you're privy to a certain form of data
though it's much more business oriented
than you know people's like browsing
habits and the rest of it yeah I mean
it's just just a high-level principle we
people need to own their own data and I
think the technology to allow that to
happen across service lines across
company lines did not exist until
recently with the blockchain
I think the blockchain presents a new
opportunity for us to create identity
wallets for people and then you get to
choose what's what services get to read
from it and also get to write from it
and you can turn that off at any time
I think it's it's one of those ideas
that needs to happen as quickly as
possible and at least so many other
beneficial things in our space that's
tremendous that that is a beautiful
vision where we actually own our data
and then there are various companies
that can make use of it with our
permission and we position you yeah and
we can turn it off at will like that
would be a whole different level of
agency for us because right now again I
you know you don't know really what the
heck is going on yeah in terms of your
data getting sold and resold packaged
and repackaged yeah and you know what's
interesting is I get a sense a lot of
the tech companies themselves they may
not know that's true I mean this is this
is hard this is hard stuff I think the
most important companies to actually
make this happen are the folks that are
actually deploying hardware because I
think it has to happen when you buy a
device when you buy a laptop when you
buy a phone when you buy a tablet if I
start on Android and I move to the Apple
ideally all these things cross connect
and just one wallet but I do think it's
it's up to the larger companies to
actually make it work together and make
this a standard and then I hope they do
and that's where I think smart
regulation could
come in in order to push them to do so
that is one of the frustrations I have
to where government has been absent from
most all of these issues for years and
decades where our legislators have a
very dim understanding of most
technology and we all saw when when Mark
Zuckerberg testified to Congress they're
asking him all these inane questions
about the operator like they when you
taught like the like it wasn't like a
surprise visit you know what I mean they
like theoretically knew he was coming
and could prepare so let's imagine for a
moment that I were pressing the United
States and you and I were talking and
you're like well thank goodness that
happened Andrew here like the three
things I really wish that the government
could intelligently get involved with
that would be a massive help to us and
let's agree that universal basic income
is one of them and that's happened and
you know that's related to technology
but not necessarily intrinsically a
techy issue like what are the top few
things that you wish an intelligent
government government could help with
I'd imagine AI is probably somewhere on
that list he is definitely on that list
and I think like when I when I talk to
global leaders and regulators around the
world they're focused on the outcomes
instead of the primitives being used to
build these technologies we have to
focus our regulation around the
primitives being used and how things are
built rather than just putting band-aids
over the outcomes you know these
algorithms are going to start making
more and more of these decisions and
they're not being built in such a way
that it's required that they explain why
that would be one you know one simple
piece of regulation is it so field of
research and they I called explain
ability really hard to do but even small
steps we take there would be meaningful
why did my watch just tell me to stand
you know just just basic things because
we're offloading more and more of our
decisions to these algorithms and like
you've all said in this book if we don't
understand why we're doing it and why
they're making these decisions we've
just you know we've basically giving up
our our agency completely
why did I turn left just that also when
we think of AI we the algorithms but
more important is the data and it's very
hard for a start-up right now to build a
compelling AI algorithm without access
to massive amounts of data which are
owned by very very few companies right
now Google Facebook Amazon Apple
apparently the public sector has vast
troves of data that are not being made
available to commercial actors like
Twitter or even academics this is one
thing that I know we could help with
very quickly where the the public sector
governments are sitting on like traffic
patterns to weather - like you know -
like soil quality like there are things
that we could do that companies could do
if they had more access and owned and I
think that brings to another point is
like if you're a president I would ask
you like how do we how do we establish a
stronger partnership between technology
companies and government and NGOs and
the media because all four of these have
a significant part to play in how
society functions and there's faults in
every single one of them right now and
all of our institutions companies media
government have lost a lot of our trust
and that can be very isolating yes and
it's very hard to solve problems with
their constructive yeah
so I guess those are the three things I
would ask the the rebuilding of trust is
something I'm very passionate about Jack
yeah because you know you can just look
at the polling and see that our trust in
like you said media government financial
institutions schools hospitals probably
pre-crisis I think our trust has
probably gone up the most trusted
institution in American life right now I
believe is still the US military like
that like the the presidency it's
collapsed and that
that's pre Trump and so to me one of the
big precursors to solving these problems
in many ways is a restoration of trust
and so if you have these institutions
that have been failing us in many many
regards for a long time it's hard to
then say okay that institution has been
failing me for a long time but now I
trust it again yeah exactly I and I
think we are we have to decompose trust
like how do you earn trust in the first
place I think transparency is one way to
earn it
I think accountability is another way to
earn it I think reliability and being
dependent was another way to earn it but
there's there's it there's a matrix of
ways to earn trust and they need to be
ranked and they need to they need to be
applied to all these institutions but
more importantly to connections between
the institutions I think that is what's
failing us the most right now everyone
is he's so isolated your idea of
partnership between government media
tech companies and NGOs is profound
we should a hundred percent do that well
that's something I heard a lot from Joe
Cinda the prime minister of New Zealand
and and this was right after the
Christchurch call so like she you know
she she also was trying to push like
this is not just the government or
technical technology companies this is
the media - yeah if we you know a lot of
a lot of the videos being shared on on
Twitter after that we're not you know we
we're not individuals on Twitter they
were actually reporters on Twitter
even though just in - and and Primus or
Jacinta and the country asked those not
to be shared so we have to collaborate
more otherwise you know everything that
we're we're going to be facing will just
not work you know Jack I believe that
universal basic income is central to a
restoration of trust yeah where if a
society actually invests in you in a
real way and says hey look here's money
then you actually become more trusting
and optimistic or you like
okay like you actually do value me care
about me you'll invest in me in my
future you'll invest in my kids in my
future because people can tell when
you're bullshitting them honestly it's
like if you say to them hey you're great
like you're a citizen it's important
they're like you know like young people
at this point I'm like yeah but if
you're like hey you're important we'd
love you and here's money and we're not
even gonna tell you what to do with it
like we trust you exactly love you
that's not actually a game-changer I
can't tell you jack like I I randomly
like bed mode someone money and yeah I
know you've done the same thing like I
got there yes huge cash app it's the
future I did but just like the act of
someone receiving money it's like like
they can't believe it and just like when
our government you know even sent those
$1,200 checks like no one believed it
until it was in their account like
really there's so much built-up distrust
and skepticism that when you actually
get that money like it diffuses it it's
about to me actually restoring trust in
people humanity our society our way of
life the fact that we actually care
about each other oh yeah I mean I live
by the principle if everything is
connected so if someone is in pain I'm
in pain ultimately over time and I want
to make sure that I'm doing whatever I
can in my lifetime to to help that
through my company's works through my
own personal giving and I'm in I'm in a
situation that I never imagined when I
was a kid or when I was 25 or I didn't
have any aspect of like what money would
mean until I was probably 35 and I I I'm
so grateful but part of gratitude is not
just saying I'm grateful it's doing it
gratitude through Action Man may that be
like the theme of this
[Music]
all right if you're listening to this
you are obviously a fan of podcasts and
one of the best podcasts out there is
the Jordan Harbinger show it's an apple
top 50 podcasts it's one of Apple's best
2018 podcasts and well and we love it
it's got a frankly a range of topics
ranging from talking to FBI negotiators
about how to deal with hostage
situations you've got mental health
situations you've got Tony Hawk on there
you've got such a wide range of topics
and Jordan such a fascinating guy so
it's not pop psychology your superficial
advice or BS inspirational nonsense it's
a show that offers meaningful fun
life-changing insights with a practical
edge and I love the worksheets because I
come away with like what I'm supposed to
do from an episode like this and there's
no BS it's very straightforward and
simple for someone like me yeah yeah
it's really good listening good learning
good information from experts that you
kind of wish you had access to and now
Jordan's done it for you check out the
Jordan Harbinger show Jordan Harbinger
comso I subscribe on Apple Spotify
wherever you get your podcasts it seems
to me like you were actually ahead of me
and universal basic income it's not like
you needed Andrew yang so it would love
to hear from you as to like how you
originally were exposed to it over the
past number of years and how you became
such a staunch believer and champion of
it over the over the past few years just
seeing everything happening with AI and
specifically in square we you know we
serve sellers and their employees are
cashiers and we can see the writing on
the wall in terms of the need for people
behind those those cashiers we saw this
when we had an app called
caviar which is a food delivery which is
basically moving the point-of-sale to
the customers hand the restaurants don't
need someone managing the cashier
anymore if they shift or more more
delivery
and we we see that throughout the
business and that you know we talk a lot
about the we talk a lot about the
self-driving trucks in and whatnot and
this is even coming for programming like
a lot of the goals of machine learning
and deep learning is to write the
software itself over time so a lot of
entry-level programming jobs will just
not be as relevant anymore
so every single field is going to be
touched by automation and ubi to me
represented a floor the floor the people
could stand on and really have the
knowledge and peace of mind ultimately
that they could survive and eat and feed
their children while they are learning
how to transition into this new world it
doesn't mean that they don't work it
means that they have a floor with which
to build and to get to a skill stack
that would be more relevant in this in
this future so I think that's one aspect
of it and and I think the only way we
answer these questions ultimately is
through experimentation now so so Jack
that's where we connected while I was
running for president that I was like
you very very concerned about the impact
of automation and technology and you
were closer to it than obviously just
about anybody and one of the things I've
been saying is that this pandemic this
crisis is accelerating the rate of
change that we had expected where I've
been saying we're seeing 10 years of
progress or change in 10 weeks and is
that similar to what you've seen and
what you what you've seen companies
investing in oh yeah I mean like just on
the square so just the shift towards
online has been has been break fast and
like it's it's just been incredible to
see how people are shifting and you know
that when you're when you're online you
don't need a cashier so I mean it does
affect real lives
and it's certainly efficient for the
business owner but it's not great for
their employees and that's why we need
to look inwards and and really make sure
that we're taking care of of everyone
and especially our most vulnerable
throughout this process as a shift
happens and I am optimistic that a shift
can happen but but people need that
peace of mind in order to just face it
in the first place well yeah it's hard
for the shift to happen that people
can't put food on the table and like our
work about paying next month's rent now
I feel like square must give you one of
the best dashboards and know what's
happening to small businesses right now
that most anyone has I just saw this
study that said they think that 30
percent of small businesses might shut
their doors forever what are you seeing
at square in terms of what's happening
to local entrepreneurs IRA sellers have
been super creative in terms of like
hacking the system and trying to figure
out new ways of doing things so all of
our restaurants shifted to curbside
pickup and delivery we had a bunch of
salons who shifted towards doing
FaceTime based or zoom based style
constant consultations so a lot of
creativity is emerging but you're right
yeah there are a lot of people I could
use that right now they're growing
everywhere I wasn't suggesting that Jack
I was just generalizing so true but yes
so we are seeing a lot of creativity and
I'm really optimistic about that but I
mean the reality is that we're seeing a
lot of people have to lay off all of
their employees we're seeing a lot of
folks who are so providers to shut down
completely and and for a lot of people
this is their dream I mean this has been
their dream for years and years and
years and they've worked so hard to
build this up and it's just been it's
been devastating so we're we're doing
everything that we can to support it but
there are limits to that and one of the
things I'm proud of is
we were a vehicle for the for the PPP
second round we were able to get out
over five hundred million dollars to our
sellers next day weeks ahead of all
banks and and it it's it's just been
amazing to see that lifeline extended
but I don't ultimately think that's
enough we have to we have to figure out
how these sellers will change their
models and you know a lot of these
things some of these things will not
reemerge but some some well in just a
different format and and that's what I'm
excited to help folks to that makes me
so happy that Square was actually a
conduit for some of that PPP money
because I was thinking about those food
truck operators and nail salons and just
thinking how the heck are they gonna
access that money you know it's like a
lot of them don't have like a private
banker they can call the fact that some
of them called you and actually got that
money actually makes me really glad yeah
we had over 500 million to about 60,000
sellers across the country
in every every state and it was from so
proprietors I think about 40% of them
were employers and 60% were so
proprietors Wow
yeah I mean those are really like you
said they're living their dream you know
they had this idea for a small business
and they go out on a limb and that's one
of the tragedies of this economic
collapse is you know it's affecting the
local entrepreneurs the most it's it's
also just such a massive part of our
economy and every single economy around
the world like it's over 51% the small
business economy is over 51% of almost
every national economy around the world
yeah it's the job driver to in in our
economy and every other economy you know
when you're seeing just the seriousness
of this crisis led you to do something
that is singular in our entire country
which is you've pledged 1 billion
dollars in philanthropy to a combination
of COBIT relief helping girls and women
and universal basic income and Jack I
gotta say like you see that headline
I remember you texted me when you were
announcing and I was like I got chills I
told you I was like that is the greatest
thing I've ever seen because a billion
dollars at the time was reported to be
something like 28 percent of your net
worth you know and and so people look up
and and you know if you're worth several
billion dollars which you are it's an
unfathomable amount of money to the vast
majority of people but then everyone can
understand 28 percent of one's net worth
like what drove you to such a massive
commitment that really is singular right
now in our society well I I think there
are a lot of there are a lot of people
doing things privately but I thought it
was important that we added more
transparency to this because a lot of
these things tend to be fairly dark and
invisible and you don't really see the
the impact and we we launched this with
a Google sheet which was just kind of a
fast hacky way to do things but the
intention was it was very Jack Dorsey by
the way the intention was not not only
to show where we're giving each each row
has the amount and the org and their
mission and and what these funds will go
towards and also a link to the website
for people to to click into and learn
more or contribute themselves so not
only to attract what we're doing but
also to learn like we aren't going to
make mistakes in this and I want to make
sure that we can annotate this sheet and
and just show people where on why we we
made this mistake so I thought that
transparency was really important and
the other I think creative thing that we
did is I'm not a liquid billionaire I I
have equity in these two companies and I
moved the square equity a billion
dollars worth at that at that day to an
LLC and that LLC then gives it to a
daffy over time def is a donor advised
fund so the cool thing is that the
original billion I get I gave in the LLC
is now worth 1.5 point already that's
incredible we did move 200
into the death and and they sold it on
the market and we now have 200 million
of cash to to work with and we've we've
now we've now granted over 86 million of
the of the 200 so far we've been able to
move fairly fast but a lot of a lot of
it has been due to the incredible work
that existing foundations already have I
don't want to build a foundation I don't
want to create a bunch of overhead and
when all the money to go to the people
in need so we it's only two people it's
myself and my my assistants a chef a
chaff staff Vanessa we want to keep it
fairly light and really directed on
these three problems of covered response
girls health and education and then
universal basic income experimentation
well I have to say that's the leanest
thing anyone's ever heard of in
philanthropy two people a Google Doc a
billion dollars and we're gonna use this
occasion to make an announcement which
is that I think humanity forward
actually is making that Google Doc the
coolest Google Doc in the world yeah
yeah we're we're doing that we're doing
five million for humanity for it and
your work and and I just I really
appreciate who you are first and
foremost but also what you're doing I
think this idea is long overdue and I
think the only way that we can change
policy is by experimenting and showing
case studies of why this works and a
number of other countries have proven
small experiments as well but we have to
do it here and I just your your voice in
bringing this to the public conversation
and the global public conversation has
been incredible and I'm just so grateful
because we need this and we need this as
soon as possible well thank you Jack I
can't tell you how much I appreciate
that and I can tell you exactly where
the five million dollars is going to go
we are going to give it to people
just sort of taking a page from your
book we're going to just turn around and
distribute micro grants of generally
$250 to thousands of people that you
will make possible so I can't tell you
how grateful I am personally and how
grateful everyone who's going to be
benefiting from this gift will be
because I see the requests we get and
they are legion and heartbreaking
there's just so much needed around the
country right now and we've been in a
situation where we've raised and
distributed 1.5 million or so a little
bit more but this 5 million is a godsend
and is going to change thousands of
lives so I can't tell you how much this
is going to mean to so many people hello
everyone
when I was running for president we
mailed a lot of stuff and so what we did
is we went to stamps comm and bought one
of those cool scales we had them in the
office it became this freaking post
office out of the office that I have to
say gave me some real pleasure every
time I passed it because I'm a big
believer in mail in the post office I
think the fact that we're talking about
the post office going out of business is
nonsense it's like the purpose of the
government is to fund stuff exactly like
the post office now when you want stamps
you can go to the post office
or you can just go to stamps comm which
is what we did and that was a home run
for us right now
listeners too yang speaks get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment so if
you mail lots of stuff this is your
chance just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in yang that stamps
comm enter yang
i I want to give up I want to give up
all my money in my lifetime I want to
see the impacts selfishly in my lifetime
and I want to make sure that we're we're
helping people that's a good kind of
selfish Jack I want it I want to see I
want to see that that impact and that's
just like I mean when when you build
something like a Twitter or square that
the greatest value is actually seeing
someone else use it that's what drives
us
it feels electric I mean the first time
that we saw tweets from Iran it felt in
electric it felt amazing the first time
we saw like one of my favorite coffee
stores in San Francisco using square and
choosing it themselves that would be
fine just walk in did you sure they
didn't choose it because they recognized
you positive and then and then even
better is when my mom went into her
favorite coffee store that is Betty
Lewis and she saw it and she texted me
and so like that that electricity that I
feel in those moments is the same that
I'm feeling right now when I give and
when I know that these orgs that were
giving to our focused on giving real
impact and and doing things that are
bigger than all of us and especially me
so I just want to learn as quickly as
possible and how to do it the right way
knowing that I'll make mistakes and
knowing that I'll have a ton of advice
coming at me because this spreadsheet is
open and and and that's that's great and
I know exactly where your money's gonna
go where we're concerned that like every
dollar is going to go into the hands of
a struggling American family and it's
just like like you're giving us the
ability to have that kind of impact on
people's lives really I cannot tell you
how grateful I like just like as a human
being I like I I just it's beyond words
really because without someone like you
making this kind of move then we're just
faced with the need and like and you
know and then looking at the need and
like you you have to have confidence
that you're going to get resources but
you don't know and then because of you
now we're going to have these resources
I just hope that other people follow
your example and want that same feeling
that you just described Jack aye-aye-aye
I hope so I've had that feeling too and
it's awesome
like people called me the Asian Oprah
for a little while on the trail and I
wasn't even to do it that much but
thanks to you we're gonna be able to do
a lot more and I think there's a real
appetite for universal basic income
right now because of the magnitude of
the changes that were faced hundred
percent and also because of of your
voice I mean you you did put this on the
national stage and you know it's been an
idea that's that's talked about in this
country since we're on Luther King and
maybe maybe before that but you you
really reminded us all of the importance
of it and what I appreciate it about you
so much is that you you you were talking
about the problems of the future that
we're not we're not addressing enough
right now like we only have so much time
to address these things and if the small
steps were taking today compound into
experiments that change and inform
inform and change policy success I mean
that's awesome and the more we can do in
the space the better yeah it's one of
the frustrations I have is that we've
committed 2.8 trillion or so least
Congress has towards relief in various
forms and right now there are other
bills being proposed and let's call it
three trillion dollars I'd be like ten
thousand a person I can't help but think
that most Americans if you gave them a
choice between ten thousand a person a
whole host of other things like we would
probably choose Direct Relief because
we're like well I know I'll get it and I
know that my neighbor will get it yeah I
agree I mean like it's just a tragedy to
see this money going to the banks and
larger companies when it could be going
into the hands of individuals in this
country and they like giving people
money entrusting them to do the right
thing will have positive impact it will
and
I think that the case against ubi in the
in the past has been you can't just give
everyone money because they'll just
waste it no that's not the case like it
will have positive impact and they will
do the right things they don't specifies
the right things but we need to we need
to trust our people and we need to trust
the people of this country in other
world
just such a pleasure Jack you know I
feel honored to be having this
conversation with you and this time of
need for so many and your role model
don't - more than you know I mean really
like just knowing that you are you and
doing what you're doing like makes me
and other people feel like amazing
things are possible we can't eradicate
poverty we can turn this crisis into
something that actually accelerates
positive change as well as negative we
can build a better way of life and
you're going to be an enormous leader in
that we can and it's been an honor to
talk to our future president well thank
you for saying so man yeah well thank
you I appreciate it and I appreciate
your support during the campaign - like
that that meant a lot at the time and
yeah we'll be back at it you know like
the gang gang what will my parents will
be happy would be so happy yeah I can't
wait to meet your mom I saw her tweets
that she's like does that make me like
the grandma Twitter she has quite a
rambunctious grandchild she chew off
more than than she was bargaining for
[Music]